you know where my favorite place to shop
is my couch
it's therapeutic for me i love online
shopping i
really do like i am a complete convert
and that's why i'm so excited that we've
teamed up with rue la la
which is an online store where you can
get high quality designer items at
insane prices
and now here with this week's hot
rue la la items is my friend kelana
barfield brown
hi drew hi
okay i have some great items today from
rue la la
bring it on get into it let's get into
it okay we're gonna start
with this melange weighted compression
blanket they're
so comfortable like fill it it feels
like you're being wrapped in a
big hug this one's great we actually
have it in two different weights this
one's 15 pounds but we also have it in
20 pounds if you want to go a little
heavier
these are truly important right now
i think a lot of people are gravitating
towards weighted blankets
they produce chemicals that release in
the body that feel
safe and comforted yep these are the
times for it
perfect people are upping the weightage
in these blankets and this is
not just a vanity thing or a comfort
thing there
is scientific evidence to back this up
and what
what the benefits are totally this is a
game changer it is a game changer it's
so cozy
i mean like you said we're home and it's
going to if it's going to soothe us
i feel like this is a great investment
in your self-care so basically if it's a
bad day you just go like this
now you call it a day
okay get this these retail elsewhere for
239.
today we're getting them for 99.99
that's a 58
discount and this is
all the rage it's all the rage i love it
yeah
okay next item oh yes the next item
are these earrings that i'm wearing they
are from deepa gernani
and they are handmade design they're
beaded they're gorgeous
i love those red ones i actually think
they look great with your mustard you
should put them on
am i going to go ketchup and mustard i
love them i love them so much
i'm putting them on right now so these
earrings are handmade in india and
they're available
in various colors for me as a woman i
find
a little lipstick and an earring is
so transformative so fast those are
gorgeous on you really those are
gorgeous
i love those i love them i love it i
love it
thank you they're amazing and guess what
they normally go for sixty dollars today
we're getting them for 23.99
oh that's a good 60 discount now
that i love that price point 20 23
give them all to me 23.
i'll take all of them you know we love
to talk about beauty products
so this is the skin nation orange
blossom five piece illumination set
and this is really a comprehensive
skincare set it has everything you need
it has your
face wash it has your moisturizer your
eye gel
your serum it's all here so you don't
have to guess it's
all here and the products are really
really great yeah so this retails
elsewhere for 255
but today you can get it for 99.99
that's a 60
discount wow that's also
again when you break it down you're
getting
five steps right at 99.
kalana i would pretty much buy any
skincare that you pushed
because can someone please kelana has
the most beautiful skin i was just
staring at it your skin is perfect thank
you
okay our final product is this face mask
that we see right here it's a treatment
mask this is from eight elements it's
their led
face and neck photon multi-treatment
mask okay first of all i've never seen
one for the neck
it's for the face and neck and i always
feel like the neck gets deprived don't
you feel like that
you get older and that neck by the way
catches up with you right luke i am your
father
okay it has seven different photon light
therapies and that's what makes it so
great
and it really does help to treat fine
lines and wrinkles
age spots hyperpigmentation all of that
and these are so expensive this retails
for 6 500
today we are getting it for 199.99
that's a 96 discount
this is a complete skill i have never
seen one that has this many colors yeah
and each and every color
really has a purpose so i love this
because you can really tailor it to
whatever your need is oh you're going
through all the colors
this is amazing i'm i am so excited i i
love allowing me to get to try this
definitely
and for any of you guys at home that
want to look up these items all you have
to do is go to ruelala.com
the drewberrymore show and remember
these deals are only available while
supplies last that mask is going to be
gone and
really fast
[Music]
you